for a presenter of the final award we've
stepped outside the industry we've
remained true to Los Angeles however I'd
call him the town's most distinguished
son he achieved the miracle of Peace in
Palestine he won the Nobel Prize he is
now one of the large figures in the
United Nations organization it is an
honor for all of us to hear from dr.
Ralph Bunche
mr. Astor members of the Academy ladies
and gentlemen it seems to me that there
is little if anything more that needs to
be said tonight
this brilliant occasion speaks
impressively for itself and no words of
mine can add any luster to it the Run
for the Oscars is a memorable experience
and I am greatly privileged to be here
tonight it's inspiring to see
outstanding achievement rewarded in this
vast and highly competitive realm of the
motion picture in which arts and
industry are so happily combined to
excel in the utilization of the most
powerful and effective mass medium the
world knows must be extremely satisfying
if only because of the great social
significance of the medium itself it is
imperative to our way of life that this
great medium be kept fully free as the
press radio and television must be but
in our society freedom always must be
accompanied by sober responsibilities
and obligations and I need scarcely
stress how vital it is that the motion
picture industry not only be directed
toward democratic objectives but conduct
itself always democratically precisely
because of the universality of its
appeal and its impact the United Nations
looks to the motion picture and to those
engaged in the industry
for constructive and understanding
assistance in achieving ultimately a
world of peace and Brotherhood the
United Nations itself of course is not
without its drama and its comedy and yes
it's acting too without calling any
names it is apparent that we have had
some made-to-order
heroes and villains and I fear that even
a trace of Pam could be found now and
then in United Nations meeting we in the
United Nations are bold enough to
believe that with persistent and
undismayed efforts and with the help of
people of great goodwill everywhere
honorable peace can be achieved
unsecured and Brotherhood can be made to
have everyday meaning in the lives of
all men and now to the business at hand
nominations for the best film of 1950
are the following All About Eve 20th
Century Fox born yesterday
Columbia father of the bride
metro-goldwyn-mayer King Solomon's Mines
metro-goldwyn-mayer and Sunset Boulevard
tarimov may I have the envelope please I
am happy to announce that the winner is
all about
- Darla stomach buzz come to the stage
to accept award
Best Motion Picture mentions of the All
About Eve this picture received 14
nominations for Academy Awards this year
setting a new record
thank you very much I've said it all and
I want to thank again everyone the 20th
Century Fox and particularly I want to
thank someone that you've already well
rewarded tonight thank you Joe it's time
for the trumpets to sound along salute
to the film achievements of 1950 the
Academy thanks you in the audience and
you listening over the air for your
interest in good picture it is a high
privilege to serve you good night